I've talked about containerization
on this channel before,
but this video is different
because it includes the phrase
"hundred-tonne autonomous robots".
New Zealand is a long way from almost
everywhere else on the planet.
Humans only reached here
about 700 years ago.
If you look at a globe of the earth,
in almost every direction
for thousands of miles
there's nothing but ocean.
Which means that the
Ports of Auckland here
and the other ports like it
all around the country
are vital to keeping New Zealand running.
- Well the fantastic thing about the
Ports of Auckland
is that we're right
in the middle of the city,
but the downside of that
is that we're quite constrained.
We're not in the sixties when you could just
pave over everything and build out into the harbour.
We can't expand anymore,
so we've got a fixed footprint,
not so great when your city's growing
at a massive rate of knots.
When your get your head around the fact
that you can't do the old fashioned things
like just keep reclaiming land,
it becomes quite an exciting challenge.
How do we put the maximum
number of containers
through this little plot of land?
- Like every other
major port in the world,
almost all the goods that arrive
or leave here
are going to be in a
standardised shipping container.
For incoming goods, once a container has
been unlocked from the ship,
these giant quay cranes take it
and move it down to ground level.
And then it's moved to a holding area
by a straddle carrier,
ready for a truck or a train to take it
on the last miles of its journey.
Those straddle carriers
look like something
out of an old Gerry Anderson show,
but they're real.
They weigh 70 tonnes before they even
pick up a container
and the newest straddle carriers
which are being tested
right here, right now,
are automated.
Fully loaded, that is a hundred-tonne robot
just moving around at speed.
- We are automating while still operating
the terminal,
it's an absolutely crazy thing to do
but we have to do it because
of our space limitations.
So it's a bit like, you're
having open heart surgery
while you're still playing tennis.
So we're now getting robots which can
work much more steadily and stack higher
and stack closer together.
And so we can get a lot more capacity
out of our same piece of land.
- It's really really precise.
The A-STRADs can stack containers
with an accuracy of a
couple of centimetres.
That actually can pose a problem because
the wear and tear on the pavement
is always in the same place
at the same time.
So we've got a fairly
cool solution to that,
which is called stack shuffling.
So in a manned terminal, of course for the
straddle operators to know where
to put the containers, we
paint lines on the ground.
Over a number of years that
wears out the pavement.
We get ruts where the
straddles drive repetitively
and damage on the asphalt where the
container corners land all the time.
And of course that then requires repair,
which is disruptive and expensive.
So with A-STRADS they
refer of course to an electronic map,
they need
no lines on the ground.
So that enables us to then move the
container stacks just a little bit
and that spreads the wear
and tear on the pavement
over a much longer period of time.
- GPS isn't quite precise
enough for this job,
and there's a lot of flat steel surfaces
that could reflect or block those signals.
So there's a local positioning system
installed here as well.
Synchronised transmitters
all around the port
work like miniature GPS satellites.
And equipment on each straddle carrier
triangulates the location
using the light speed delay from each one.
Which is literally
sub-nanosecond precision.
They don't just look at
the timing signal itself,
they track the phase of each transmitter's
carrier signal.
- The Locata system is our system for the
positioning of the machines.
We have these two antennas on top of
each machine in order to also be aware
of the orientation of the
machine at each moment.
But it's a local system.
Everything which is directly related
to the main safety of the straddle carrier
is on the straddle carrier.
Also the navigation itself happens
on the straddle carrier.
- Whilst we're automating a large part
of our operation,
we're actually keeping
people in a part of it.
So we'll actually have
interactions between
manned straddle carriers and automated
straddle carriers, and that's never been done
in this way
anywhere else in the world before.
The system has multiple layers of safety.
The first one is the simplest, which is
we put a big fence around the terminal
to keep people out.
Beyond that, then, we've
got a computer system
that monitors where all the
machines are all the time
so it's both manned and
the automated straddles.
It manages the interactions between
those machines,
and it's a
standalone fail-safe system.
And then as sort of last layer of defence,
the A-STRADs have laser scanners on them
which will detect the
presence of an obstacle
in front of the machine and stop it
before there's a collision.
- We've got a different
type of automation here.
We have straddle carriers that are only
automated in part of the terminal.
And the reason we've done that
is again the throughput.
So our crane drivers are really fast,
under the crane we've got lots and lots
of steel,
it's really hard to get
those signals and automate.
So by keeping manual operations
underneath these cranes here,
and then automating the
yard, we get more capacity.
The robots do the really boring stuff
like moving containers around,
digging out the bottom one
to put it on a truck,
and the people do the really tricky stuff.
You know, the technology will no doubt
improve,
but for now, that mixture of people
and robots is the perfect mix.
- Thank you to all the team
at the Ports of Auckland.
Pull down the description for more
about them, and their work.